Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie.
They just released Spider-Man
Across the Spider-Verse on home video
in a whole bunch of deleted scenes.
An entirely different
ending in a deleted post-credits scene.
So we'll break it all down.
Also, explain what's going on
with Spider-Man beyond the Spider-Verse
the sequel.
it's been delayed a little,
but we knew that was going to happen.
So it's not a huge surprise
if you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos.
I'm giving away
a couple of copies of Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse on digital too.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and post your favorite Easter egg
for the movie.
In the comments At the end of the movie,
Miles is captured by Earth 42 Aaron Davis
and Earth 42 Miles Morales
has become the prowler on his earth
because he wasn't bitten by that
original spider that gave Miles's powers
the spot responsible for performing
the initial reactor test.
and during that,
he pulled the spider from Earth
42 to the ultimate universe
where it bit Miles Morales instead
so at the end of the movie
that has a reckoning of sorts
between earth 42 miles in the main Miles
Morales for everything that happened
or went wrong for him as a result of that
in probably one of the bigger surprises
from the movie
is that they didn't have
a traditional post-credits scene
like the first movie
Spider-Man into the Spider-Verse
there were so many Easter eggs,
like so many deep cuts
that they worked into the movie.
It was so complex
you could watch it like a billion times
and still see new Easter
eggs in the background.
you would have thought
that they would have had at least
a couple post-credits scenes to top the
post-credits scenes from the first movie.
now. Lord and Miller said that they
actually did create a post-credits scene
and then decided at the last minute
to remove it.
Just leaving things with the
Miles Morales will return in Spider-Man
Beyond the Spider-Verse tag
the deleted post-credits
scene would have been a funny moment for
the spot paying off a joke from earlier
in the movie with his character
Earlier in the movie after he discovers
how his powers work, how his holes worked,
they may hold giving him the ability
to portal anywhere in time in space,
including across dimensions.
There's a montage of him
going to all the different universes.
I've already been a big Easter eggs
video breakdown of all this,
so I'll post a link down
to the description below.
But like he goes
The Lego Universe, the live action
Venom crossover, a bunch of others.
once he figures out that he needs to
top himself off like he runs low on power,
like he starts to lose his holes
as he uses up more power.
he does that.
But he's still not that powerful yet.
he had just gone on this big tear
with Miles Morales about how he wasn't
just a villain of the week
in a sort of
pump himself up as a built like he wants
to think of himself as a big time villain.
He decides to get a drink
from the infamous secret villain hideout
called the Bar with no Name.
Pass with Love Me The hell in, you idiot.
Good one.
I've been working on it.
The bar with no name.
Watering hole for New York's
most notorious criminals.
Last time I went in there, the fight
lasted most of Labor Day weekend.
It's a bar from the Spider-Man comics
where villains just go to hang out.
he wanted to show the other Spider-Man
villains that he was a big shot, too.
But he sits at the bar
and he can't get the bartender's attention
to actually get himself a drink
for the life of him.
the joke is that nobody at the bar
with no name,
none of the other villains care about him
or notice him at all.
Eddie had just yelled at Miles Morales
about this,
which he also does later in the movie
when he says he finally be somebody
with all these extra dark matter upgrades
when he made himself more powerful,
when he's at the bar
the first time, he finally steals a drink
using his holes and pours it down,
it leaks out of his other holes,
like he can't actually consume anything.
this that?
This was meant to pay off some of the
visual metaphor of his character,
like trying to fill a hole in his heart
with more holes.
Not a great method.
so all the other Spider-Man villains
start laughing at him
and most of the other villains
that were there
at the bar
are villains that you see in the montages.
Earlier in the movie.
So he leaves the bar
with no name in disgrace
that first time
kind of getting laughed out.
He goes to a couple other worlds, getting
more dark matter, getting more powerful.
Eventually they have the events
on Spider-Man, Indias world in Mumbai,
and he gets the huge power upgrade.
And that's the last we see of him
in the theatrical cut in the deleted
post-credits scene they would have shown
in Portland back to the bar with no name
and he sits proudly in the coveted booth,
as they call it, like the place of honor,
the bar reserved
for the most feared villains like Kingpin
He calls out all the previous Spider-Man
villains that had made fun of him
and then dispatches them
like big bar fights.
They ended in a giant bar fight.
this is what they actually said
about the bar
with no name
when they were putting it in the movie.
Even hardened supervillains need a safe
space where they can drink their cares
away In the company of Spider-Man's
ever growing number of enemies.
introduced in Captain America Number 318
cover Date June 1986
New York City's bar with no name
is precisely such a spot located
in an abandoned subway station.
The bar is where we see
a spot interact with Hammerhead
in some of the other bad guys.
While a tough as nails bartender,
Delilah keeps an eye on him
and encourages him to stand up for himself
Incidentally,
the shady underworld types are not allowed
to practice their superpowers
while they're on the premises.
Spot, however, breaks the rules by showing
some of his portal creating skills
to Grizzly Jack Lantern, Hammerhead
and some of the shady types at the joint
or character Designers went back
to the original comics to include
a diverse group of characters
and featured them in this bar scene.
It was a lot of fun deciding
which supervillains to include.
We wanted them to be updated,
but definitely identifiable versions
of some familiar characters.
there was also a big deleted
scene of Earth, 42 miles practicing
with Aaron Davis,
teaching him to become the Prowler
like the younger Earth, 42 Miles Morales
before he became the problem.
Officially, as he was trying to learn
the ropes.
were Aaron Davis is still the prowler
you could see him in his suit here
teaching a slightly younger looking miles
G Morales is they're calling him
that's what they're calling this
prowler version of miles from earth 42.
and it looks like they're stealing
medical supplies
from the Sinister Six cartel and
giving them to his mother at her hospital
just because she doesn't have enough
to treat her patients.
So she's very thankful
but doesn't completely realize
what's actually going on.
Like, oh, some vigilante left me supplies.
there was also some tie in material
in some of the art books
that they released that teased.
What's going on with this Miles G.
Morales alternate reality prowler version
of the character to confirming that
he's kind of a Robin Hood
type of character
vigilantes stealing to help his mother,
stealing from the rich, a.k.a.
the Sinister
Six cartel, giving to the poor.
and if you look at a lot of his
moves, too, they're very Spider-Man
like in the way that he's web
slinging around kind of using Prowler
tech, almost doing the exact same thing.
He looks very similar or his moves look
very similar to the regular Miles Morales.
Spider-Man's
he just doesn't have any actual webbing
so he's using practical technology
and it seems like his mother
in this reality and earth 42 doesn't know
that he's becoming the prowler
or has become the prowler
she probably only knows
that there's a vigilante out there
that calls themself
the prowler that's in the news.
Who helps her,
gives people things that they need.
But just like regular Miles
Morales mother, she also hasn't
totally figured out that this Miles
Morales her Miles Morales
hasn't become the prowler on their world.
so a lot of people were wondering
what's going to happen
after the end of Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse
because they tease this big fight
between the two of them, like he's slowly
escaping using his shocker ability
it's meant to be a big callback
to Spider-Man into the spider-verse,
where Peter
Parker used his abilities to escape
while Miles was talking to him.
so Miles is going to start Spider-Man
be on the Spider-Verse
doing the same thing,
escaping from this situation
and even though the way
they play the music, like the big reveal,
they want you to think like Miles
Morales is a villain.
The idea is that
they're trying to tell you through
all these tie ins in these teasers
that really he's a vigilante.
He's not an outright villain.
That was what the regular Miles
Morales Spider-Man was talking to Earth
42 Aaron Davis about before he realized
what was really going on.
he was trying to tell him
about his Uncle Aaron before he died.
He wanted to be good,
but he didn't know how.
so they want to let you know that
that's kind of going on with this Miles G.
Morales Prowler version of the character.
a lot of people were wondering
if they're actually going to fight
or if they're going to take a hard left
turn and just surprise everyone
and he won't be a villain.
Like he'll actually help this version
of Spider-Man.
Miles Morales my early theory
and some of my previous videos
is that he would eventually do that,
but there'd be like a small fight,
Like you have to have them fight
just a little bit.
But the end game idea is the prowler.
Miles Morales.
Miles Morales is not going to wind up
being a villain.
my other early theory is that he would
eventually wind up fighting the Sinister
Six cartel on his earth,
and they would set
those group of characters
up as bigger villains on Earth.
42 they won't walk back Miles Morales
Spider bite or anything like that.
Like he'll go back to his ultimate
universe Earth. but.
At the end of the day, Miles
Morales will just continue
becoming a better version of the Prowler
and become more of a good character,
so to speak, more of a traditional,
good character
trying to defeat the Sinister Six cartel
there will be a group super powerful
on this earth, it's
not something
that he would completely wrap up
during beyond the spider-verse
like he would just continue
fighting the Sinister
Six cartel on his earth into adulthood.
so part of the idea
is that even in an alternate reality,
even though things went completely
terrible for him, like his father died,
he didn't become Spider-Man,
the traditional type of hero.
Things still worked out
like he's still good in this reality.
Fundamentally,
there was a longer character
description for this prowler,
Miles Morales two that they released.
So it says Miles Morales, a.k.a.
The Prowler, is the alternate reality
version of Miles,
who grew up completely different from him.
this version of the character
was never bitten by a radioactive spider
and doesn't have any superpowers.
But he has fallen into the role
of becoming a vigilante.
The Prowler notices this A vigilante,
not villain.
under the tutelage of his uncle,
Aaron, Miles comes face to face
with his other version of himself
and realizes
that because one thing
dropped the other way,
everything has changed due to the
butterfly effect, where one small change
can later result in larger changes
to a deterministic, non-linear system.
in this case an entire reality, says
director Justin Kate Thompson Internally,
we decided to call this parallel world
version Miles G.
Morales To avoid confusion.
So we think that just confirms
that we'll see like a very brief miles
versus miles G.
MORALES At the beginning of Spider-Man,
beyond the Spider-Verse
until they both realize what's going on.
Oh, we're not bad people.
We want to help each other.
the other big thing
that they tease much earlier in the film,
too, is that Miles leaves his mother like
this is the last time that he sees her
in this movie saying that he promised
that he would come back and he promised
that he would have a nice cake.
That's not all messed up So early
prediction is that's how they end.
Beyond the spider-verse,
they stopped the spot from collapsing.
All of reality.
Spider-Man 2099 comes around on him
and finally leaves him alone
and they have some shawarma tags
seen at the end of the movie
where he comes
home to his parents with a nice cake and
introduces them to the rest of his friends
that he mentioned at the beginning
of across the Spider-Verse
and they all eat cake that he brings back
with him, including Spider Ham.
Like, it would be funny to see his parents
meeting Spider him.
It can get weirder.
he was also trying to tell his parents
his secret identity
like he was about to tell his mother
a couple of times.
Then he tells the wrong earth
40 to mother.
He'll probably tell his parents
that he is Spider-Man
at the end of the movie to in the other
Easter egg here is also for this earth
42 version of miles like the prowler miles
being the other cake in the equation
like the two different cakes are the
two different miles.
earlier in the movie,
his guidance counselor is telling him
about this metaphor for his future
and being a cake and trying to bake this
good cake. And he's like, well,
what if you just bake two different cakes?
You could have your cake and eat it, too.
just another Easter egg foreshadowing.
I think the two of them working together.
we'll probably start
getting some more beyond
the Spider-Verse teasers later this year.
So of course I'll do more videos as we see
more Easter eggs or deleted scenes,
so leave all your requests in the comments
below.
Click here for my Spider-Man
Beyond the Spider-Verse Teaser Trailer
Video and click here for my brand
new Loki Season 2 trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!